has left town without a coronavirus  relief bill  lawmakers failed to come to any  compromise on an aid package before  taking their week-long holiday break  today  senate majority leader mitch mcconnell  proposed that congress shift 455 billion  dollars of  unspent small business lending funds  toward a new measure  meanwhile florida's rick scott has  become the ninth senator  to test positive for either the virus or  antibodies  and just into fox news donald trump jr  has tested positive  a spokesman says the president's son got  the news on monday  he has been asymptomatic so far though  he has been quarantining at his cabin in  upstate new york  and is following medical guidelines the  fact that he has no symptoms  has led don jr according to sources to  believe that it might have been a false  positive so he is going to go for  another coronavirus test